[Musique]
oui c'est bon Albert ok il nous faut 15
minutes le temps de terminer les sacs et
il faut en compte dès qu'on est sur le
départ
leur mission est confidentielle ils sont
spécialistes dans l'art de la
dissimulation et s'infiltre par tous les
moyens
ces commandos du 13e régiment de dragon
parachutistes maîtrise l'art de pénétrer
les lignes ennemies
[Musique]
cette nuit dans le plus grand secret
c'est caméléons vont se fondre dans la
population pour collecter du
renseignement
l'objectif voir sans être vu
[Musique]
entre fin sur les analyses en utilisant
thermique qui nous permet de voir bien
ce qu'ils font tenir donc on verra très
bien la personne faire les gestes s'il y
a des échanges de d'armement ou quoi que
ce soit on le verra
de précieuses informations récoltées
autant d'indices susceptibles de prévoir
les prémices d'un conflit des éléments
d'aide à la décision et à la
planification d'action militaire aussi
immersion dans le monde de l'invisible
celui du renseignement militaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aucune opération militaire ne peut être
conduite sans renseignement il faut
gagner la guerre avant la guerre comme
la firme le général burqar le chef
d'état-major des armées dans sa vision
stratégique c'est encore plus vrai
aujourd'hui où les guerres hybrides se
conjuguent à la combinaison permanente
de la compétition de la contestation
voire de l'affrontement alors accédez à
la réalité d'une situation et anticiper
celle de demain à une époque où certains
sont en mesure de la falsifier c'est le
défi de la DRM la Direction du
renseignement militaire au quotidien
c'est 2000 spécialistes civiles et
militaires en lien avec les unités
renseignement des trois armées mais tout
en œuvre pour conserver un temps d'avant
sur nos adversaires ou compétiteurs
un bon renseignement c'est un
renseignement fiable donc quelque part
recouper c'était un enseignement qui est
qui est unique et qui permet quelque
part d'être valorisé soit en les
changeant contre un autre très bon
renseignement qu'on n'arrive pas à
obtenir soit parce qu'il apporte à notre
hiérarchie au niveau politique au niveau
militaire une vraie vision des choses
sans être influencé par d'autres
d'autres pays ou d'autres acteurs
installez au coeur du ministère des
armées à Paris ainsi qu'à Creil dans
l'Oise la DRM a été créée en 1992 à
l'issue de la guerre du Golfe
trois missions principales la première
c'est la pie aux opérations vous savez
que la France est engagée dans de
nombreuses opérations au quotidien et
donc il faut donner du renseignement à
nos militaires en opération il y a la
pression autonome de situation qui doit
être donné également à nos dirigeants à
la fois politique et militaire et puis
il y a l'évaluation de la menace à long
terme et donc dans 20 ans dans 25 ans
quelle menace nous devons faire face et
comment on dit préparer des milliers de
données sont ainsi collectées et
analysés par les experts de la DRM leur
objectif faire ressortir la bonne
information le renseignement d'intérêt
militaire se construit à partir d'un
cycle immuable tout d'abord la DRM
oriente ses recherches en fonction des
demandes des autorités politiques et
militaires puis elle met en oeuvre ses
capteurs et semis à disposition par les
armées pour recueillir des informations
ces données brutes sont ensuite
interprétées par des spécialistes qui
les traduire en un renseignement
pertinent enfin la DRM transmet se
renseignement au décideur politique au
chef militaire et aux forces en
opération
[Musique]
les données récoltées proviennent de
quatre grands domaines le renseignement
d'origine humaine le renseignement
d'origine cyber le renseignement
d'origine électromagnétique qui englobe
tous les moyens de télécommunication et
le renseignement d'origine image des
images
issues des satellites d'observation
d'avion de surveillance ou de drones
[Musique]
chaque jour la DRM reçoit plus d'un
millier d'images et certaines
proviennent de cet appareil
20 mètres d'envergure une discrétion
sonore et visuelle assurée une endurance
de vol allant jusqu'à 24 heures le drone
Reaper stationné au Niger dans le cadre
de l'opération barkhane et sur la base
aérienne 79 de Cognac en France embarque
des capteurs
ultra modernes
ça reste le renseignement donc le
capteur principaux bien entendu sont la
boule donc est un ensemble optique donc
capable de voir deux jours de nuit
différents niveaux de zoom mais vraiment
de faire de leur enseignement sur de
longues périodes et c'est complété donc
par un capteur radar qui permet de faire
de l'imagerie radar et du suivi de
mobile
avec plus de 40 000 heures de vol depuis
son engagement le système Reaper joue un
rôle clé dans les opérations menées dans
la bande saelo saharienne
et donc le repère bien entendu par sa
persistance aérienne voilà observer une
situation pendant plusieurs heures voire
plusieurs jours et c'est ce qui va
permettre vraiment de tomber sur le
moment où la nuit va montrer des signes
suspects et de transmettre ces signes
suppléés après la chaîne de commandement
qui prendra sa décision toute
connaissance de cause il faut se sortir
de cette malgame qui fait avec une
caméra volante l'équipage et la la pour
analyser la vidéo donc ce qui sort en
fait vraiment du système renseignement
Reaper c'est du renseignement et pas de
l'information
pour les toutes dernières informations
que nous avons reçues d'une livraison de
matériel suspect aurait été livré donc
au camp direct à l'aide d'utilitaires au
vu des observations qui ont été faites
c'est probablement du matériel qui
servirait donc à la confection de l'idée
on sait qu'ils ont cette capacité donc
au niveau des personnels on cherche en
particulier notre personne d'intérêt
plutôt trapu habillé type paramilitaire
éventuellement avec un chèche rouge ou
blanc pour l'utilisation des capteurs au
vu de ce qu'on recherche on va plutôt
faire un champ large un peu au début et
c'est détecter les véhicules du coup tu
vois quelque chose qui t'intéresse
n'hésite pas à le dire en zoom dessus
pour caractériser un peu plus finement
passer la couleur essayer de voir ce que
c'est si ça nous intéresse ou pas ok bon
bah du coup par rapport à la mission
dans le cockpit de conduite du Reaper le
capitaine Antoine opérateur capteur
pilote la boule octronic à l'aide de sa
console il navigue entre les
fonctionnalités afin d'optimiser la
collecte du renseignement si je vais
pouvoir aller chercher du détail donc
zoomer dézoomer et en fonction de ce que
je recherche ou avec mes capteurs pour
voir que ce soit de la thermique ou de
la couleur voilà on recherche à quelques
mètres seulement dans le cockpit
renseignement l'opérateur image analyse
le flux vidéo de la caméra embarquée à
l'aide de capture d'image il renseigne
l'activité observée
dans l'écran
utilitaires véhicule de gamme civil
véhicules un peu plus militaire donc du
pick-up du pick-up armé et pareil pour
tout ce qui est personnel on va essayer
de faire ressortir au maximum la couleur
des vêtements s'y porte un couvre-chef
magnifique le plus dur après ça va être
de voir de l'armement puisque les hommes
sur le terrain sont conscients qui sont
observés donc ils cachent de plus en
plus leur armement donc c'est là que
notre œil entraîné permet de détecter
l'armement arriver
on va voir ce que bien sûr on sait
qu'ils ont des ils font des IED alors
donc bien sûr on était assez sensibles
en fait des personnes les interactions
où est-ce qu'il a été dans quel véhicule
il monte avec il est etc
tel un chef d'orchestre le coordinateur
tactique assure l'interface entre
l'équipage et l'extérieur du cockpit
connecté à la chaîne hiérarchique il
transmet en temps réel le renseignement
collecté qui est le premier snap je
serai fana pour le récupérer pour
pouvoir l'intégrer l'envoyer en temps
réel je te donne le snap ok merci
depuis 2020 l'Armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace a fait l'acquisition de deux
systèmes plus modernes encore le Reaper
bloque 5 un nouveau standard au
fonctionnalités accrues liaison mieux
sécurisé vidéo en haute définition mais
ce n'est pas tout
la grosse plus-value effectivement
d'avoir une capacité rom qui va arriver
à l'horizon 2022 c'est de rentrer dans
la vraie dimension multi capteur c'est à
dire que là on aura de l'imagerie du
renseignement d'origine
électromagnétique et donc ça permettra
la séparer de dynamiser encore plus la
boucle des opérations dans le sens où si
on arrive à avoir une détection
électromagnétique
d'un élément particulier on pourra tout
de suite corréler cette détection
électromagnétique avec de l'image et
donc là c'est pareil donner encore plus
d'éléments au chef pour lui donner une
situation vraiment très claire
en attendant la DRM peut compter sur les
grandes oreilles de l'armée de terre au
pied des Vosges sur la route des vins
d'Alsace les antennes du centre de
guerre électroniques du 44e régiment de
transmission se dresse à la fois
imposante et énigmatique c'est un des
lieux les mieux protégés de France les
plus secrets aussi ce centre unique en
son genre dont la partie enterrée
représente l'équivalent de deux terrains
de football fonctionnent 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7
le centre de gain électronique a été un
ouvrage qui a été conçu dans une logique
post-guerre froide et donc c'est une
infrastructure très lourde sécurisée qui
est capable de résister aux agressions
les plus dures dans le cadre d'un
conflit de haute intensité
est-ce que vous avez pu suivre
l'activité de l'état-major
la mission de ce centre produire du
renseignement électromagnétique le
renseignement d'origine
électromagnétique consiste à intercepter
une émission électromagnétique qui a été
mise à partir de n'importe quel type de
moyen de télécommunication et notre
objectif est de récupérer l'information
qui est transmise entre deux émettent
ces données proviennent de fax d'appels
téléphoniques ou encore de liaisons auto
kiwoki pour des raisons de
confidentialité nous ne connaîtrons pas
la portée des antennes une chose est
sûre ici les opérateurs d'interception
les analyses du signal et les
traducteurs travaillent tous les jours à
partir de Sibler réels
actuellement je prends l'interception
que vous voyez ici en graphique et je la
retranscrit sur mon PV pour pouvoir
tirer de l'information donc c'est en
code Morse ça c'est un langage qui se
traduit directement en clair
mais avant de retranscrire le signal il
faut parfois le casser un signal c'est
un petit peu comme un oignon on
transporte une information à la base et
en fait on va on va rajouter des couches
par dessus et en fait mon boulot moi
c'est à partir de ce que j'intercède
c'est retrouver en enlevant les couches
l'information
la circulation de l'information est un
vecteur important voire décisif surtout
sur les théâtres d'opération
c'est pour cette raison que le régiment
est également doté d'une composante
mobile
le rôle du module de déploiement
d'urgence qui est le module lourd du
régiment et basé sur les mêmes systèmes
que ce que vous avez pu voir au centre
de guerre électronique et nous assurons
en opération extérieure la continuité du
centre de guerre électronique mais
déployé sur le terrain sur différents
théâtres en tout temps et en tout lieu
alors nous travaillons au profit du
commandement du renseignement et de
l'armée de terre mais également au
profit de la Direction du renseignement
militaire c'est-à-dire que nos cibles
sont définies par la Direction du
renseignement militaire et elle est
directement destinataire de toute notre
production renseignements donc tout sera
fusionné à la fois à l'échelle du
théâtre par les groupements de recherche
multicapteurs et par la Direction du
renseignement militaire
un peu plus loin c'est un module léger
d'urgence plus rapidement projetable qui
a été monté
alors moi petit point de détails j'ai vu
tout à l'heure ton équipe de montage tu
as donné les ordres c'était clair par
contre attention toi de bien les
contrôler aussi d'accord
chaque détail à son importance un
matériel mal monté c'est le risque d'une
mission avortée et donc d'une
interruption des interceptions
tout il faut tout prendre en compte il
faut surtout prendre le terrain en
compte avec un petit peu tout ce qui est
électromagnétique enfin surtout
magnétique là vous quand on regarde un
petit peu il y a du barbelé il y a pas
mal de grillage donc on fait attention à
notre zone d'implantation et surtout
c'est un gros travail qui est fait en
amont justement pour arriver sur zone et
se déployer au plus rapidement et
obtenir justement du renseignement
d'intérimité au plus vite l'émission
qu'on suit nous apportent une une
certaine fierté parce que on est
vraiment au contact sans être vraiment
sur les lignes de front donc on a tout
dans les oreilles et c'est en se sent
vraiment impliqué dans ce qu'on fait on
se passionne vraiment très facilement au
métier parce que en fait la technologie
dans laquelle on travaille évolue
constamment
un bon technologie c'est ce qu'a réalisé
le ministère des armées en lançant en
novembre dernier Cérès un système
spatial de renseignement
électromagnétiques unique en Europe
cette constellation de 3 satellites est
capable de détecter des radars et des
émetteurs de télécommunication depuis
l'espace avec une couverture mondiale
elle peut désormais collecter des
données sur des zones jusque-là
inaccessibles et apporter aux armées une
connaissance plus précise des capacités
et des intentions adverses qu'elles
proviennent de l'armée de l'air de
l'armée de terre de la Marine nationale
ou des capteurs de la DRM les
informations collectées peuvent s'avérer
capital notamment dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme
c'est précieux renseignements ont permis
à l'armée française de neutraliser le
chef du groupe état islamique au Grand
Sahara Adnan Abou Walid al sahraoui
c'était l'été dernier les pilote d'une
longue traque
ça faisait en fait 4 ans que la DRM
c'était focalisé sur le IGS donc l'état
islamique Grand Sahara et donc le la
connaissance qu'avec cumulé
l'ADM au moment où le président
Macron nous demande au sommet de Pau de
faire l'effort sur le IGS était déjà
important et donc en deux ans
nous avons réussi quelque part à
localiser les têtes de chêne de l'EGS et
grâce aux armées grâce au cosse réussir
neutraliser et faire prisonnier
tous les responsables de la IGS
aujourd'hui alors c'est pas définitif
puisque bien sûr le ils ont il y a une
capacité quelque part à se régénérer
mais au moins pendant quelques mois et
quelques années on a fortement les
organisé l'état islamique au grand Sart
le résultat d'un travail d'équipe engagé
avec les armées la DGSE et les services
américains
[Musique]
face à l'évolution constante des menaces
les coopérations entre services
multiplient en France on parle
d'ailleurs de la communauté nationale du
renseignement qui est composé de 6
entités la DGSE la DRM la drsd pour
Direction du renseignement et de la
sécurité de défense sont rattachés au
ministère des armées la DGSI direction
générale de la sécurité intérieure
dépend du ministère de l'Intérieur enfin
la direction nationale du renseignement
et des enquêtes douanières ainsi que
Tracfin qui lutte contre les circuits
financiers clandestins appartiennent au
ministère de l'économie des finances et
de la relance
et au-delà de cette communauté nationale
on va dire qu'il y a une communauté
aussi internationale et nous sommes
présents à travers les services de
l'OTAN les services de l'Union
européenne et nous avons également des
partenariats bilatéraux ou multilatéraux
en fonction des différentes régions et
donc très souvent nous réunissons entre
directeur du renseignement militaire au
sein de la région par exemple un
opacifique ou sur des sujets très
spécifiques que sont la Corée du Nord
des rencontres durant lesquelles il
n'est pas rare d'échanger du
renseignement à haute valeur ajoutée et
pour en obtenir l'ADN peut s'appuyer sur
ses pôles d'expertise comme le centre de
renseignements géostats armés à la
pointe dans le domaine du g.oint le
renseignement géostat
la particularité c'est que c'est du
renseignement géo référencé et daté donc
on fusionne de la donnée provenant
désarmées des terres d'opération et des
partenaires de l'ADN nous notre
interaction avec les autres sont de la
Terre elle est de fait quotidienne
puisque nous on doit se s'alimenter avec
des flûtes de données
l'ensemble du renseignement collecté sur
une zone géographique étant si réunie
sur une même carte il est ensuite
analysé d'un point de vue spatial et
temporel
pour faire parler ces données de
nouveaux métiers ont fait leur
apparition à la croisée entre la
géographie et l'informatique ces
spécialistes du géo int sont pour 40%
d'entre eux issus du secteur civil
historiquement reçoit des notes et donc
il fait d'analyse de texte et c'est
beaucoup la mémoire de l'analyse qui
constitue la base de connaissances pour
le G8 la base de connaissances la base
de données puisque on doit en avoir
suffisamment pour produire des notes de
qualité pour nous aider à comprendre les
événements parfois peut-être même à les
anticiper dans le renseignement même
bien savoir ce qui va se passer demain
le jeu wind a permis sur des opérations
récentes au Sahel d'identifier des modes
d'action un petit peu d'anticiper des
lieux de vie des lieux de repos pour
aider à la manœuvre finale ça aide les
opérations c'est bien notre finalité en
appui aux opérations
pour chaque région du monde plus d'une
dizaine d'experts collaborent analyses
de renseignements d'origine
électromagnétique cybernétique ou humain
cartographe ou même interprète image
qui permet d'accéder en ville on cherche
la présence de pick-up et de pick-up art
mais dans le secteur ici on peut
observer effectivement une ligne de
merlan qui protège l'ensemble de la
ville et ici une position défensive
sur lequel on observe la présence de
plusieurs pick-up que je vais donc aller
peloter pour les ajouter en base de
données tout plot logistique en fait qui
pourra être utilisé par l'ennemi dans le
secteur pour quadriller parfaitement le
terrain cette zone va être étudiée en
parallèle à partir d'autres données
va nous permettre d'apprendre un certain
nombre d'informations sur la
communication où est-ce qu'elle a eu
lieu à quelle heure quel jour qui est-ce
qu'elle a mis en contact avec qui
qu'est-ce qui s'est dit c'est donner
vous aussi nous permettre d'avoir un
certain nombre d'éléments qui vont être
analysés afin de déterminer si
l'activité semble d'intérêt et si elle
est hostile ou non le recoupement de ces
renseignements va permettre ensuite à
l'analyse géospatiale d'exploiter ses
données avec un autre regard
le véritable travail de l'analyse on va
traiter ces données sur une grille
d'analyse qui va permettre de comparer
dans le temps et dans l'espace
l'évolution de ces phénomènes toutes ces
données vont permettre de réaliser une
analyse qui va être par la suite
diffuser au décideurs politiques et
militaires ainsi qu'aux forces donc le
jury
profite à aux trois niveaux de
commandement le niveau stratégique donc
le niveau eau pour nos plus hautes
autorités politiques et militaires en
transmettant des cartes et des notes de
synthèse d'aide à la décision mais aussi
au niveau opératif donc pour les
Commandeurs de nos théâtres d'opérations
pour les aider dans leur planification
dans leur conduite de leurs opérations
et enfin quand la formation est
suffisamment précise quand on a surement
de données là si jusqu'au niveau
tactique et on va intégrer ces données
dans le système de préparation des
forces
avec la multiplicité des capteurs le
volume des informations à exploser pour
relever le défi de ce que l'on appelle
le mur de la donnée la DRM a entamé une
transformation nécessaire après 30 ans
d'existence
c'est un gros bateau auquel on a rajouté
différentes couches au fil du temps et
au fil des évolutions donc on a rajouté
des centres experts contre terrorisme on
a rajouté des centres experts cybers on
a rajouté des centres experts
géographiques mais maintenant il faut
créer de la cohérence tout ça et donc
l'idée maîtresse ça va être de
rapprocher la recherche de l'analyse et
de créer donc des plateaux à la fois
géographiques et des plateaux
thématiques dans les prochaines années
la transformation de la DRM s'accompagne
également d'une révolution numérique
pour être au rendez-vous du Big Data le
ministère des armées s'est doté d'une
solution souveraine utilisant les
dernières technologies qui combinent
intelligence artificielle et traitement
massif de données multi source c'est le
programme Artemisia l'un des cas d'usage
concerne le renseignement militaire
tout part des capteurs vous avez des
satellites dans l'espace vous avez des
avions dans le ciel avec des radars vous
avez des radars au sol vous avez des
caméras de vidéosurveillance ou des
caméras qui sont embarquées dans des
véhicules et tous ces capteurs génèrent
beaucoup de données donc ces données
sont rapatriés vers la plateforme à
travers des réseaux sécurisés et ensuite
dans la plateforme on traite
automatiquement ces données une fois que
ces données sont stockées on applique
sur ces données des traitements de
d'intelligence artificielle qui vont
alimenter un moteur de recherche
intelligent cet outil en fait les
analystes vont pouvoir avec une seule
requête récupérer toutes les
informations qui sont relatives par
exemple à une personne
le but essentiel aussi c'est de
faciliter clairement le travail de
l'analyse de justement visualiser la
donnée d'une manière bien plus intuitive
que ce que l'on est capable de faire
actuellement en lui proposant à la fois
un seul espace de travail où il va
pouvoir corréler recouper ces
informations
Artemisia propose différents filtres
pour préciser la recherche de l'analyse
visualisation cartographique fristes
temporelle graves relationnels
de cette solution souveraine le
regroupement d'acteurs français du
numérique la société ATA qui réunit Atos
et Thalès c'est aussi rapproché
d'entreprise comme Capgemini sopra stere
groupe et si startups
c'est à dire je rentre demander le nom à
une lettre après et le système me
renvoie quand même à peu près tous les
noms qui matchent qui correspondent à la
recherche que je viens de faire oui
alors dans les prochains développements
seront pris en compte la sémantique et
les erreurs potentielles
orthographiques
on constate c'est que utiliser des
technologies qui existent aujourd'hui
sont sur le marché ne suffit pas et que
pour répondre à aux contraintes
spécifiques du monde à la défense et en
particulier celle du monde du
renseignement tout ce qui concerne la
gestion de la confidentialité des
données donc c'est important le type de
développement spécifique qu'on a dû
faire mais qui est aussi une des raisons
d'être projet Artemis donc pour ça on a
mis en place avec la DRM une démarche de
développement qu'on appelle agile dans
lesquels on travaille main dans la main
avec eux
c'est vraiment de la co-construction
avec ce programme nous sommes clairement
engagés dans une course de vitesse et
c'est pour cela que nous travaillons
aussi étroitement avec les industriels
et la Direction générale de l'armement
pour pouvoir être beaucoup plus efficace
dans les développements les équipes de
la Direction générale de l'armement et
de la Direction du renseignement
militaire sont actuellement en phase
d'expérimentation le programme Artemisia
sera pleinement opérationnel en 2023 il
devrait bouleverser le mode de
traitement de la donnée
des objectifs principaux du programme
Artémisia pour la direction et
l'enseignements militaire c'est
justement d'accélérer le tempo de
l'analyse au profit des opérations et
donc ça va concerner à la fois bien
évidemment la Direction du renseignement
militaire mais aussi toute la chaîne de
renseignements qu'on appelle la fonction
interarmée du renseignement justement et
qui irrigue jusqu'au plus près des
opérations la DRM c'est réorganisé déjà
en interne et c'est doté d'outils pour
pouvoir répondre en quelques heures à ce
genre d'interrogations là avec Artemis
le but c'est de passer sous la barre des
quelques dizaines de minutes pour
analyser le renseignement et le
transmettre le plus rapidement possible
aux opérations
d'autres fonctionnalités seront
proposées par cette plateforme parmi
elles un qui de développement qui
permettra aux forces armées et aux
industriels de créer des applications
immédiatement compatibles avec Artemisia
et de capter rapidement les innovations
pour leur enseignement d'intérêt
militaires la révolution est en marche
les nouvelles technologies numériques
vont profondément renouveler les modes
d'action et faire évoluer les métiers
une transformation indispensable pour
assurer la tractivité du renseignement
militaire en ligne de mire le
recrutement et la fidélisation de ces
soldats de l'ombre ultra connectés qui
au quotidien contribuent à la sécurité
des Français
[Musique]